what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
members of the Rob core what is up guys
I'm sure a lot of you guys are just like
quarter pals
what quarter vows okay so here is the
deal here's the explanation on this I
get questions all the time I want to
read Batman where do I start I want to
read Superman what do I start Wonder
Woman Justice League for whatever reason
I don't understand cyborg you know but
whatever the case may be if people are
just like I'm interested in this
character and or team and I want to know
where to start or will you make a video
on this now a lot of you guys have said
that my upload schedule seemed kind of
confusing that I was covering too many
series and it was hard to keep track and
that's true that was a legitimate
complaint we had DC rivers and then
Green Lantern we had only while
different Marvel and then classic
spider-man superior spider-man that kind
of thing and so I figured way I'd go
ahead and do I've always tried to hold
off from doing this since I try to
maintain some measure of expectation on
when certain videos are going to be out
but what we're going to do is we're
going to basically update my video
schedule we're going to switch things
around so in the description you will
find an updated video schedule where
basically every day has its own video
style so there is a day for the new 52
which are all the stories that lead into
DC rebirth there is a day for classic
Marvel basically everything before
Secret Wars there is a day for all-new
all-different marvel everything after
Secret Wars there is a day for Geoff
Johns Green Lantern run it'll take us
forever to finish there's a day for
indie comics well I kind of get stuff in
a day for how to kill superheroes
everything that you need will be in that
schedule so those of you guys who only
care about classic Marvel will only find
classic Marvel on the classic Marvel
days those of you guys who only care
about DC rebirth so on and so forth that
kind of thing for all the video styles
that are listed below
this is really just kind of testing the
waters just really kind of seeing how
you guys respond to this having said
that for those of you guys who are new
to DC comics the new 52 leads into DC
rebirth so everything labeled new 52
will be before DC rebirth now I have
playlist on Batman and stuff like that
what we're going to do is we're going to
take me to these new 52 videos and we're
going to put them before all the DC
leave our stuff that way you could watch
the playlist in chronological order and
not have to worry about anything I'll
take care of all the organization on
this side so all you have to do is just
click the video and watch and you don't
have to try to figure out the viewing
order or anything along those lines so
the fact remains here new 52 Batman
quarter valves it's the best Batman
sword ever was there I say the best
thing coming out of DC
technically I guess I guess the best
thing leading into DC rebirth there we
go Scott Snyder as the guy who was
writing a story alongside Gregor Pula
they did not originator at least Scott
Snyder did not originate on Batman with
court of owls in fact he wrote a story
before the new 52 called Batman Black
Mirror I was not wildly partial to it
but Scott Snyder and Greko Pulos run on
Batman in the new 52 is critically
acclaimed people absolutely love it
there was one time I want to go see
scott snyder at New York Comic Con it
was right at the end of his run on
Batman in gamers like that and the line
was out the door
and around the building it was crazy how
long long it was to see him it was one
of the nuttiest things that I've ever
seen the fact remains here with regards
to quarter Valens getting into the story
proper because I'm sure a lot of you
guys are just like get to the story man
with regards to court of owls this is
cool because what it initially shows us
is just Batman being Batman right
because keep in mind this was the
introduction of a lot of people to
Batman comics many people knew who
Batman was he's a household name you
know he's a staple of pop culture in
general a staple of American society if
not world society and so because of that
you know people getting into this are
basically you know just kind of picking
this up with Batman just beating the
hell out of people at Arkham Asylum now
really it's just kind of like a revolt
you know people have managed to make
their way out of their cells we're not
really told how explicitly and it's not
wildly relevant but the funny thing is
that in the middle of all this we end up
having the Joker joining the fray now on
the surface this presented a really
interesting scenario and the reason why
is because of the fact that the Joker is
very much a wild card in the Batman
mythos even just the DC landscape as a
whole the Joker could pop up anywhere
the Joker to show up in Metropolis the
Joker to show up in Keystone City where
you know Jay Garrick is that the Auris
Jay Garrick was at the Joker could pop
up in Central City you know he could pop
up in Coast City he could pop up all
over the place that's one of the cool
things is you never know when he will
appear at the same time whenever the
Joker does show up whether he appears to
a villain or a good guy
no one knows what'll happen maybe he's
there to just lend his a for whatever
reason or maybe he's there to just kill
everyone regardless like the Joker will
show up and just implement these schemes
that makes sense to no one but himself
and so with the Joker being here the
idea is that he basically starts
fighting on behalf of Batman and the
fighting thing is that the
dillan response to this vo well Joker's
lost his mind Joker's gone crazy one of
the world's going on here why is yoga
fighting alongside Batman now this is
kind of cool because the conflict in and
of itself is just wrapped up really fast
I mean it's not designed to be grandiose
it's just designed to be hey guys here's
what Batman is about in the new 52
he's very similar to the Batman that you
remember now one thing that I do want to
point out here is that when the new 52
first started superheroes had basically
only been around for about five years
and so the idea of Batman you know Bruce
Wayne being Batman for for a decade or
so you know for years and years and
years and years that was gone
not only that Jim Gordon was still
relatively new to Bruce Wayne and so the
trust that we were used to in a pre new
52 continuity the trusted then built up
between Jim Gordon and Batman wasn't
there they were effectively starting off
fresh and so because of that Jim Gordon
does trust Batman to a degree but
nowhere near the way that he did before
the new fridge' - he still looks at him
still kinda believes you know what maybe
Batman's a little bit nefarious and
you're that man he's a vigilante maybe
he's not necessarily on our side 100% of
the time Jim Gordon's still putting some
feelings out of feelers out there he's
still trying to get a lay of the land
with regards to balan of course he
doesn't know it's Bruce Wayne but still
trying to get a lay of the land with
regards to the Batman character now
following this we basically end up
finding out that you know the Joker was
essentially Dick Grayson in disguise
which is cool which is actually kind of
interesting to see Batman employing
these different forms of subterfuge
against villains and everything's like
that kind of throwing them off kilter
and and so on but the other half of this
is basically the public space that
Batman puts on the face of Bruce Wayne
and that's was kind of ironic about the
Batman character we look at that man and
we say okay look there's Bruce Wayne and
there's Batman but in truth the real
person is Batman the face that the world
sees is Bruce Wayne it's almost like the
line from Kill Bill you know where he
was talking about the staple of
superhero mythology and Superman and
Clark Kent because that kind of thing
Bruce Wayne is the alter ego that's the
disguise that's the face that gets put
onto the world Batman is the actual
identity and that's what makes it so
cool is because Bruce Wayne is basically
Batman that's who he is
at his core Bruce Wayne is just the mask
that he puts on when he talks to the
world but the other half of this is it
shows us all the charitable works and
the kind of thing that he gets into of
course this whole notion that for the
most part he focuses heavily on the idea
of trying to make Gotham City a better
place so it's a multi-faceted attempt to
basically make Gotham better it's not
enough to fight crime it has to be
something where he basically improves on
impoverished areas he gives money to the
kind of charities that can do good in
the city so again it's really focusing
on the idea that that Bruce Wayne trying
to save Gotham is a two-sided coin you
know one side is beating up criminals in
the middle of the night as Batman the
other side is putting money where it can
best be used as Bruce Wayne and so
finally this we actually pick up with
Harvey Bullock and we pick up with that
man with a burning sign that says you
know Bruce Wayne will die tomorrow that
kind of thing but the other half of this
as there's also a guy who's basically
been pinned to the wall and been
injected with a ton of knives now this
is where the court of owls begins to
come into play and this is one of the
reasons why the court of owls was so
cool is because we end up finding out
there is a lot going on in the realm of
Gotham that Batman just doesn't know
about what is up happening is they
basically pick up with you know Batman
and Jim go I'm sorry Jim Gordon and guy
that does autopsies and stuff the name
escapes me but you know we took it with
them kind of analyzing this body and
then of course Batman shows up and
Batman Begins going through and of
course what we end up finding is that in
one of his teeth is a filling and inside
this filling is an owl symbol and the
whole notion is that this ties into an
old rhyme that Bruce Wayne members as a
kid about the court of owls and
especially the way the rhyme went it was
one of those things where it was like
the court of owls is this nefarious
group that exists under ground behind
Gotham City and if you talk bad about
them they'll come and find you
one of the things that this really
seemed to hit home at is that it was a
children's run it was designed to
basically keep kids in check if you
don't do your homework the court of owls
will come and get you if you treat
people bad the court of owls will come
and get you they'll sue the talent and
the talent will take you away you know
but you never know where the court of
owls was at it was really really spooky
when I first read this because the idea
of Bruce Wayne not knowing about this
nefarious organization that exists
within the realm of Gotham City is just
kind of mind-blowing right like Bruce
Lee knows Gotham in and out he knows it
like the back of his hand and that's the
beauty of court of owls is it takes the
idea that Batman is Gotham and
philippson on his head
and says maybe there are things about
Gotham did Batman doesn't know about
that Batman is totally unaware now of
course what this does
says look you know kind of Christmas
timetable of sorts where Batman has 12
hours before you know whatever it is it
happens to leads to his death but this
actually comes I guess really kind of
brings us to a meeting between Lincoln
March and Bruce Wayne now Lincoln March
is a guy who's basically running for
mayor he's running for a major position
and Gotham City proper but the way that
the kind of facade he puts on here and
really the way he engaged in Bruce Wayne
is that they are very very much similar
that's kind of a cool thing here is
Bruce Wayne wants to put money where
Bohr can best be used
Lincoln March can make that happen
Lincoln March can basically say hey look
here are the areas where money can best
be spent in the city I've combed over
you know all the different areas that
are that are basically struggling the
areas that are a little more abject I
guess telling an abject poverty than
anything else money can be put in these
different places and it can be used the
most effectively the problem with this
is that in the middle of this whole
discussion we basically end up running
directly into the talent now the talent
is effectively the long arm of the court
about you know he is the guy the court
of owls sends out to take out those
individuals who they've deemed to be a
threat which is to say those individuals
that they want to have killed now the
funny thing about this is that Scott
Snyder does a really good job of sort of
going through and teasing these
different concepts teasing these
different ideas of how far back the
court of owls go is for example the
Talon makes the statement how I love
killing wanes and so for the question
that was being presented here when this
story first dropped is is the court of
owls responsible for the death of Thomas
and Martha Wayne now it creates kind of
a funny situation because historically
speaking in DC Comics you know really in
almost every iteration of Batman's
origin Thomas and Martha Wayne
were basically killed by Joe Chill there
were times where the motivations of Joe
Chill were changed but he was always the
guy that killed him now more often than
not it was just Joe Chill was a guy who
was down on his luck and he was
struggling and he came across them and
they were people who looked as you know
looked as though they came from wealth
they had you know jewelry so on and so
forth and in the midst of the situation
of the heat of the moment he pulled the
trigger and killed him both there's also
been other things where it's like you
know Joe Joe was a monster and so on and
so forth but the fact remains here that
Joe Chill murdering the parents of Bruce
Wayne is a core aspect of his of his
whole story this is one of the things
that really kind of kind of intrigued
people it was the question of is that
the
is this really what's going on now of
course in the middle of this fight
between between Batman and and the
talent one of the other things that
Scott Steiner really hits at is the idea
of how well Batman knows Gotham City for
example in this whole rooftop fight we
end up having a scenario where they both
fall out of the building and the result
is that the Bruce Wayne basically says I
know this city like the back of my hand
I know where the gargoyles are
positioned around this building and so I
know where to jump out I know where to
go I know how to make sure that I can
survive by grabbing on to something the
Talon doesn't know that and so we're you
know Bruce Wayne jumps onto this
gargoyle of tau and presumably falls to
his death only for us to find out that
the talent is very much alive which is
revealed to us when he basically kills
the paramedics so again what we end up
doing is we basically follow this this
path that Bruce Wayne's going on
anywhere to learn everything that's
going on let's do half of this Scott
Snyder spent a lot of time focusing on
the notion of Bruce Wayne very much
being a detective Bruce Wayne very much
being a guy who doesn't just go out and
beat people up and like you know punch
around criminals and stuff like that he
uses his mind as much as he uses his
fists and his feet and so it's kind of
cool because it's got Snyder basically
reaffirming what existing Batman fans
already know and in forming new Batman
fans that Bruce Wayne is a multi-faceted
guy he's a jack of all trades and a
master of all trades he knows how to do
it all this eventually leads into Bruce
Wayne meeting directly with Lincoln
March of course Lincoln March having
been injured in the assault but Lincoln
basically kind of issues out this
morning to Bruce Wayne this is look man
you have to watch out for the court of
owls now one major theme here is that
Bruce was like there is no court of owls
I would know if the court of owls exists
I'm Batman if the court of owls is there
I know about it I know Gotham better
than anybody and if the court of owls
was was real I guarantee they would have
been arrested or I'd be keeping tabs on
them or something like that
now what Lincoln does is he gives us
like this really really spooky situation
you know we bait he's basically kind of
told you know look I was warned by the
court of owls and what they did is they
basically put like a little owl nests
with some bones in my home when I came
home I found that there and that's
really what the court of owls does they
issue these little warnings you know and
it's just kind of like a hey back off
like we're watching you whatever it is
that you're doing we don't like now
Scott Snyder also just kind of goes to
this idea that it's like a big thing
right I mean the court of owls is not
give you you know a warning because you
went to the wrong grocery store what it
is is someone like Lincoln March that
wants to issue a whole bunch of change
around the city of Gotham is working
against the interests of the court eval
so it's basically Scott Snyder dropping
these clues and essentially telling us
that were the court of owls that they
are very much rooted in the history of
Gotham indicating here that the court of
owls are basically composed of some of
Gotham's wealthy
we know what goes on with them now but
at the time of this story we didn't know
that but again this all really follows
the idea of Batman investigating further
a Batman going through and trying to
figure everything out now just by virtue
of his own investigations and his own
resources what Batman ends up doing is
basically going to all these different
buildings that are funded by the Allan
Wayne trust for young architects in in
Gotham City basically those individuals
that are there being giving charity
money for the purpose of improving
Gotham City skyline and every time he
goes to the 13th floor he ends up
finding this small little place where
evidence of the court of owls exists and
all of them seem to be locations of
where the Talon resides now the reason
why this was kind of important is
because scott snyder gives us these
really kind of spooky but really cool
instances of how smart Batman is one of
the things that he says is that cities
are by definition very superstitious
places people you know keep all kinds of
superstitions you hate their salt over
their shoulder and different things like
that it's not something that happens all
the time but there are people who are
there Allen Wayne was a very
superstitious member of the Wayne family
and the result was that throughout his
own life he believed the number 13 was
unlucky as did a multitude of people and
so back in the early days of when SIDS
are being built when people were still
very superstitious we may build
buildings they would skip over the 13th
floor he would just go from 12 to 14 and
the result is that you would keep this
little section of the building where the
13th floor would normally be and that
would basically house the bad luck and
so in the mind of Roose Wayne if the
court of owls exists that would most
likely be where they would reside or
where evidence would belong and as he
goes through every single one of these
buildings that's exactly what he finds
he basically finds stockpiles of arms
and armament he finds all kinds of
things that belong to the court of owls
and documentation photographs that
proves their existence now in the mind
of Batman he's still not 100% on board
even after he goes into one of the bill
buildings and he basically after
activates a trip device that ends up
resulting in as you know in a massive
explosion that almost causes him to die
he still has a hard time believing it to
be true and the reason why is because of
the fact that in a conversation that he
has with Dick Grayson we end up learning
the following the death of Bruce Wayne's
parents that he believed the court of
owls was behind it as a child he had
heard the nursery rhyme he'd heard the
stories heard the tales and thought the
court of owls may have been the ones who
would let all this look what he ended up
doing was going around and doing all
this different research now again this
is Snyder showing us how early Batman's
detective skills were honed and used and
so it really showed us that the death of
his parents changed him in a fundamental
way but he started going through and
looking at all these different clues
signs of owls and different things like
that
all of which basically led him back to a
place called harbor house now
Harbor house was a former meeting ground
for Gotham's social elite now it had
long since been abandoned but it had
different signs of owls and so on and so
forth and so where Bruce Wayne as a
child had basically looked around and
believed the idea that if the court of
owls was real and they basically you
know not really worship owls so much is
strongly associated themselves with
Alice in places that would have a lot of
decoration regarding Alice would likely
be their place of business now this was
also rooted in the idea that his parents
because they were part of Gotham's
social elite and had associated with
Gotham's wealthiest individuals that
those wealthy people were probably part
of the court of owls so again this all
sort of fed into this idea that the
court of owls were the ones behind his
parents murder the problem with this is
that once he gets to where he believed
that they would be meeting or where they
would be located ultimately he finds
absolutely nothing he simply finds that
there's nothing there now in addition to
this Batman had actually exhumed Allan
Wayne's body and just kind of analyzed
his bones number things like that again
all that basically went into him kind of
tracing back the roots or the existence
of the court of owls now the reason why
was because of the fact that Allan Wayne
himself had died under mysterious
circumstances he was just found in a
sewer one day and so the result was he
was identified by his dental records
what ended up doing is it basically set
in motion this idea that if Allan Wayne
had just suddenly vanished under
mysterious circumstances if people are
being killed you know without any real
indication of why if the court of owls
does exist then the sewer may very well
hold the answer now again
is just kind of connecting these dots
he's just kind of bringing them together
in a natural progression which does make
sense but what Matt man does he says
look on the bones of Alan Wayne was this
kind of weird material kind of like a
white powder of sorts which doesn't make
any sense because of the fact that
there's no material in the sewers of
Gotham that has that same kind of
substance attached to them and so the
indication seems to be that Alan Wayne
was held in a place that was within
Gotham but not visible to the normal
human eye meaning it was very much
hidden away and so of course where he's
in the middle of this whole
investigation he's ultimately a surprise
and subdued by the talent after which he
wakes up in the labyrinth of the court
of owls now this is one of the coolest
moments and the reason why is because
this shows us how easy it is for the
court of owls to break the Batman but it
also shows us how far back they go and
how extensively they've reached out and
assassinated various people now the
court of owls as they're shown to us are
basically people who wear these al masks
are these really really cool masks over
their faces when the story came out
people were just cosplaying as court of
owls and that's all you saw at Comic
Cons were just like court eval masks and
it was so cool to see what the whole
idea is that as he goes through this
labyrinth he's effectively losing his
mind he's losing a sanity now this
appears to be a combination of isolation
and just constant exposure to life the
fact that he can't sleep I mean he's
sleep-deprived
he's almost dehydrated hungry I mean
it's just all these different things
that sort of come together for the
purpose of pushing Batman to the
absolute brink of his sanity and this
really comes to play when he
hallucinates his parents who in turn
basically begin kind of you know we
materializing and dissolving and then
turning into bats and so again it gets
really really crazy but in the middle of
all this you know when he's basically
just kind of losing his mind starting to
go insane he's attacked from behind by
the Talon and at least presumably killed
now again this is really kind of Snyder
just wrapping things up quick fast and
in a hurry but again this is really
significant here because very rarely
have we ever seen Batman out of control
which is to say not in control of his
surroundings or not Tom or not collected
that's the hallmark of Batman you know
no matter how bad it gets no matter how
terrible things are Batman is the one
guy that always stays saying he's always
the one guy there's like there's got to
be a way to think ourselves out of this
to be a way for us to initiate a plan or
to do something you know he's the
backbone of really the Justice League in
a lot of ways you got Superman who's
just pure strength you have Wonder Woman
who strengthens strategy if you have
green lantern I mean if all these
different characters Batman is the
backbone of the Justice League in terms
of his intelligence his resources his
ability to basically think himself and
others out of almost any situation to
have a plan for virtually any scenario
to see him broken to see him pushed to
the brink of almost complete and total
insanity
is crazy and it was it was absolutely
nuts to read this at the time that it
came out it was like good god like
Batman's lost his mind it was really
cool but of course what we end up having
here is the scenario of the court of
owls playing out in the sense that when
a person basically goes against the
wishes of the court when they're issued
a warning and they ignore it and they're
brought to the labyrinth to basically
kind of push to the point of insanity
and they're told you're going to lose
your mind and then we're effectively
going to kill you and basically that is
kind of sacrifice now the judgment is
made by the court themselves and the
talent is the one who carries it out and
so with the town being the agent of
Batman the television is kind of beats
them up fights them you know with the
intention of killing him and then that
man more or less just kind of falls prey
to his darker side now the way this is
shown by Greg Capullo and the way that
it's written by Scott Snyder it's a
perfect example of how a metaphor meets
reality in the sense that Batman falling
into his darker side Batman basically
losing his human nature and becoming a
dark version of himself is manifested in
terms of how he looks now he doesn't
actually look this way he hasn't grown
teeth or anything like that it's just
kind of here to show us this is where
Batman is now you know he's basically
dark he's brooding he's you know not
really evil he's just kind of lost his
humanity even if only for a temporary
amount of time and so he's very very
feral and so in this moment of
desperation in this moment of panic he
basically begins going against the Talon
and fighting him off as best he can but
the other half of this is that Scott
Steiner very much focuses on the
intelligence of Batman which is to say
that once you recover from his temporary
insanity
once you subdues the talent he also just
kind of goes back to being as
intelligent as he is and one of the
thing that he had done was that when he
was going to the labyrinth he had come
across an old camera now with regards to
the court because of the fact that
they're so rooted in antiquity because
they used so many antique things that
camera that they use dates all the way
back to the days when they basically use
magnesium in order to create flashes and
cameras now in addition to being able to
use magnesium there was also flash
powder which is a combination of
potassium chlorate and magnesium and so
what Batman basically realized was that
inside this camera was essentially a
filament plate that was made of
potassium chlorate and that because of
the fact that he's so familiar with
Gotham he was in turn able to realize
that the statue was basically white
marble instead of construction marble
which makes it easier it makes it softer
and more prone to destruction and so by
putting these two together
he basically realizes he has a way out
he ignites the potassium chlorate blows
up the fountain and escapes down through
a hole and that's the coolest thing here
is it shows us how smart Batman is how
capable he is now again this is also
basically Scott Snyder's saying that
this whole story about showing how
Batman didn't know the court of owls
existed really kind of hits home to the
idea that yes
he's not as familiar with Gotham City as
he would like but he still knows it
better than almost anybody not only that
it also shows us the arrogance and the
hubris of the court of owls and so
that's kind of Scott Schneider bringing
things back to roofs saying hey look
here's this clandestine organization
that Batman never really seemed to know
about they seemed almost you know
supernatural in terms of their form and
function but at the end of the day
they're people they're bad guys they're
arrogant they have hubris they believe
that nobody can defeat them they've
existed so long from the shadows but
they can't envision a scenario where
they could not only be discovered but
brought down and so again it's really
just kind of hitting home to the major
kind of rub everything back around to
the core of the Batman comics but the
other half of this is Rhian up finding
out that this talent was only one of
them that there have been a multitude of
towns that exist and so what we'll
actually find out in the next video is
how these towns come into existence that
is to say what the court of owls does to
create them and we also end up finding
out that there was a lot more to Dick
Grayson being a character than we
originally thought there was but if you
guys are new here two comments explain
and you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob port if you guys are
interested in this kind of new 52 thing
where we basically go back and cover the
older new 52 stories leading into DC
rebirth post a comment let me know and I
will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]
you